[Musique]
aujourd'hui à l'émission un grand
dossier sur l'état de santé des océans
malmené par les changements climatiques
et la surpêche pris d'assaut par la
pollution au plastique
comment se portent des océans et les
êtres vivants qui les habitent
[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte ça
peut sembler étonnant mais notre survie
dépend de la santé des océans et
services qu'ils nous rendent sont
immenses ils nourrissent ils sont aussi
d'importants régulateur du climat mais
les océans sont malades et les maux qui
les afflige ne cesse de prendre de
l'ampleur alors est il trop tard pour
agir y a t-il raison d'espérer voici un
bilan de santé des océans
[Musique]
la terre la planète bleue
c'est ici que nous habitons
8 milliards d'humains y vivent entourés
d'eau salée
des océans essentiels à la vie et qui
sont de plus en plus fragilisé
à tel point que notre existence sur
cette planète pourrait bien ne plus
jamais être comme avant
je crois que je suis optimiste
mais quand s'agit l'océan aujourd'hui je
suis inquiète
[Musique]
peu d'entre nous ont observé la terre
comme cathy sort leuven
cet astronaute américaine est aussi
océanographe et le regard qu'elle porte
sur notre planète est unique
j'avais l'impression simultanée de
fragilité et de pouvoir de notre planète
orvoine des orages très grand au des
courants aussi nos graphiques des
centaines de kilomètres simultanément la
fragilité ya les gans et
pouvoir grande pouvoir
on a donné cette planète de mauvais non
on l'a nommé tél on a de le nommer à
quoi
à quoi c'est le moule atteint pour oh il
y en a à la grandeur du globe
71 % de la surface de la terre et
recouvertes par des océans qui sont
interconnectées cela représente un
volume immense de 1,37 milliard de
kilomètres cubes d'eau salée encore très
largement inexploré
beaucoup reste encore à découvrir
plus de 90% des espèces présentes dans
les océans n'aurait pas encore été
répertoriés
il ya de la vie partout autant dans la
colonne d'eau que sur les fonds marins
du plateau continental près des rives
eaux plus profondes fosses abyssales
des organismes microscopiques
jusqu'aux plus grands êtres vivants
c'est énorme garde manger nourrit les
humains depuis la nuit des temps
[Musique]
et les scientifiques d'aujourd'hui crois
même pouvoir y trouver les remèdes aux
maladies de demain
[Musique]
lotion pour moi ça représente la vie
c'est à cause de l'océan de ce planète
que nous vivons
la moitié de l'oxygène
que nous respirons ça devient direct de
lotion
en plus d'être notre principale source
d'oxygène les océans influence largement
le climat de la planète
il absorbe la chaleur de l'atmosphère et
sont aussi de véritables puits qui cap
sur le gaz carbonique
mais malgré leur grande résilience les
océans sont à bout de souffle et ce
n'est pas une bonne nouvelle
là pour moi ça a renforcé une obligation
de souvenirs que
que je suis connecté
richement qu'on a fait avec toutes parts
et planète et il me faut le bien soigné
c'est la seule planète omra
cathy sun n'est pas la seule à sonner l
alarme en 2019 le groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat le giec a déposé un rapport
spécial sur l'océan lors d'une
conférence à monaco
son constat a de quoi faire frémir dans
le monde entier les océans subissent les
ardeurs du changement climatique depuis
des décennies ce qui a des conséquences
radicales et profonde sur la nature et
l'humanité
en tant que espèces les humains sont
entrés de modifier les océans de telle
façon qu'on risque de vraiment leur
nuire au niveau de la bio diversité et
l'abondance de plusieurs espèces de
poissons et invertébrés marins au québec
le physicien denis gilbert est inquiet
le chercheur à l'institut maurice
lamontagne a fait partie de la
délégation canadienne qui a travaillé à
l'adoption du rapport du giec à monaco
ma réaction principal par rapport aux
rapaces et qu' il est plus que temps que
les humains brin d'en contrôler leurs
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
avec les niveaux de co2 actuel qui
continue d'augmenter
parce qu'on utilise encore énormément de
charbon de gaz naturel et de pétrole la
tendance lourde
actuelle me force à être pessimiste
m
le système climatique de la terre et
régis principalement par les échanges
d'énergie entre l'océan et l'atmosphère
avec l'augmentation du co2 la
température de la planète se réchauffe
entraînant aussi la hausse des océans et
cela provoque son lot de bouleversements
peter galbraith est un peu comme un
docteur au chevet d'un malade
son patient le grand système que
constitue le saint laurent
donc il y à peu près une dizaine
d'années les choses ont commencé à
vraiment changer d'angle soeur ou mon
rôle est devenu beaucoup plus important
d'un sens coulisses pense quelque chose
à 20 faut pas le manquer le chercheur à
l'institut maurice-lamontagne analyse la
température des eaux afin de quantifier
les changements qui affectent les
organismes marins son diagnostic est
sans équivoque depuis ces dernières
années les eaux du saint-laurent ne
cesse de se réchauffer avec le font
chaque année c'est un petit peu plus
chaud chaque année on brise le regard
donc on y déjà d'un des températures que
le golf dans les salaires pourquoi
l'on n'est pas homogène dans le système
du saint laurent on retrouve trois
couches superposées qui se réchauffe
pour des raisons différentes
l'enjeu en surface c'est la perte du
couvert de glace en hiver qu'on voit
poindre à l'horizon à ce prochain juste
une cinquantaine d'années dans le futur
ben on va voir que le golfe saint
laurent va devenir un petit peu comme
halifax les mecs là où
la glace de mer ne sera pas à l'ifa ça
va être la même histoire pour le golfe
saint-laurent où la glace bord va se
former jusqu'à une plaie tuzla brodeur
mais on aéroport dans le golfe sauf
exception denis très fortement froide
peter galbraith est particulièrement
inquiet de ce qui arrive à la couche
d'eau profonde là où vivent de nombreux
organismes marins
cette gauche n'est pas en contact avec
l'atmosphère et elle est indépendante
des couches supérieures
sa température est influencé par les
grands courants océaniques de
l'atlantique qui eux ont commencé à être
perturbée par les changements
climatiques
donc ces eaux là nous viennent du bout
du chenal laurentien à l'extrémité
complet un des rares du golfe puis se
mélangent l'oeil de plus en plus riches
en eau chaude donc on sait que pour les
quelques prochaines années tout le moins
ça va considérer chauffer on doit s'en
inquiéter parce qu'on est sorti de
l'envelope du connu
le réchauffement des océans a un impact
bien tangible sur les humains
principalement pour les populations
côtières et insulaires c'est que le
niveau de l'eau s'est mise à monter et
ce phénomène n'est pas près de s'arrêter
l'éléphant dans la pièce qui fait peur à
tout le monde c'est la fonte des
calottes glaciaires celle du groenland
et de l'antarctique
il y à peu près deux décennies ces
fontes le guen l'année en antarctique
était relativement
mais à ces deux endroits là il ya une
accélération du phénomène
selon le giec au cours du siècle le
niveau de la mer continuera d'augmenter
comme jamais et cette hausse pourrait
atteindre 30 à 60 cm d'ici 2100 jumelé à
l'intensification des phénomènes météo
extrêmes les conséquences seront majeurs
plusieurs villes côtières et des îles de
faible élévation vont y goûter comme ami
ennemi dernièrement la conséquence
principale de
la hausse du niveau de la mer c'est que
plusieurs grandes métropoles vont être
affectés et vont devoir
savard attire toutes sortes de défense
pour protéger les infrastructures
la vie d'une grande partie de l'humanité
sera chamboulée
environ 30% de la population mondiale
habite à moins de 100 kilomètres d'une
compte
on peut s'imaginer des villes comme
shanghai des villes comme new york
essayer de se protéger
ici la ville de québec est un endroit où
il va avoir aussi des effets de la
hausse du niveau de la mer les humains
auront beau essayer de se protéger il y
à un autre problème auquel échapperont
pas
les océans nous on doit faire un grand
service à l'humanité c'est qu'ils
absorbent une grande partie du gaz
carbonique qu'on aimait mais ce
service-là via un coup c qui vient
acidifier les eaux océanes et
[Musique]
les océans absorbent plus du quart des
émissions de co2 produites par l'homme
chaque année ce dioxyde de carbone se
dissout dans l'eau et forme de l'acide
carbonique
conséquence son ph diminue et l'océan
s'édifie
processus qui risquent de s'intensifier
à proximité de la surface où l'on
retrouve une grande partie des espèces
exploitées par l'homme on est en train
de faire une expérience avec le co2 qui
a le potentiel
d'approuver rire énormément les océans
les organismes qui possède une structure
calcaire seraient touchés on pense ici
au plancton à la base de la chaîne
alimentaire
certains mollusques et crustacés aussi
pourrait avoir de la difficulté à former
leur coquille et leur squelette externe
enfin les coraux qui sont une formidable
pouponnière pour les poissons risquent
d'avoir de plus en plus de difficultés à
survivre
[Musique]
le bilan pour les océans est sombre
et les défis sont nombreux
arriverons-nous renverser la vapeur
[Musique]
arrêter le réchauffement arrêter la
signification pour cela s'agit d'arrêter
les émissions en tout cas bon
bull en hausse perd cela c'est ça la
question
[Musique]
on le voyait en introduction les océans
vivent des bouleversements sans
précédent mais quel est l'impact sur les
êtres vivants qui habitent ces
écosystèmes marins à l'ère des
changements climatiques y at il des
gagnants et des perdants cap sur le
golfe du saint laurent
[Musique]
le golfe du saint laurent est une
immense mer intérieure
[Musique]
dans les villages côtiers les bateaux de
pêche des charges de leurs cales des
poissons des crustacés et désolant curie
mais si à première vue l'activité semble
prospère tout n'est pas rose au large
[Musique]
le golf subi les contrecoups des
bouleversements qui secouent les océans
partout sur la planète
au quai de rivière au renard en gaspésie
la saison pêche à la crevette bat son
plein
comme la plupart des pêcheurs mario côté
et son fils jean frédéric ont dû
composer avec les changements qui
affectent le golfe du saint laurent
c'est ce qu'annoncé réchauffer dans le
garçon s'en rend tout temps on peut on
te pousse à cacher que ça c'est pas tous
que c'est qu'on a atteint le super
ccd sais c'est gros mais sais tu nous
autres la solution c'est une chute
cela pose la question
comme les pêcheurs les scientifiques
canadiennes se pose des questions sur
l'impact qu'a le réchauffement des eaux
sur les espèces marines pour le
biologiste hugo bourdages tout n'est pas
blanc ou noir dans le golfe du saint
laurent oui en a qui vont s'en tirer
moins bien mais on a pu en sortir et qui
montre qu'ils ont bien s'en tirer
par exemple le homard se porte à
merveille par contre des espèces comme
le crabe des neiges la crevette et le
turbo ont déjà de la difficulté à
s'acclimater
et de paban là ça réchauffe pas là qu'on
observe c'est plus un déplacement de nos
espèces dans l'espace il ya plusieurs
exemples d'espèces qui se porte bien
dans cet environnement là qui est
charles qui échangea
c'est le cas du sébaste qui est devenu
le nouveau roi du scellera en 2011-12 et
trahi on sait pas trop pourquoi
exactement mais on a vraiment gagné à la
loterie à savoir qu'on a trois courts
importante de ses bases qui sont
apparues qui vont bientôt leur rentrée à
détail appréciable pour la pêche
commerciale
le sébaste est un poisson de fond qui
peut vivre jusqu'à 75 ans comme ceux de
la morue ces stocks ont chuté de façon
dramatique dans les années 80 à tel
point qu'il a fallu imposer un moratoire
sur la pêche
mais contre toute attente des relevés
récents au chalut ont confirmé le retour
spectaculaire du sébaste dans le golfe
du saint laurent
l'année dernière d'après nos amis
90% de la bio-masse qu'on attrape et
dans le fond du golfe représentait de
ses basques si on compare avec le porter
c'est un poteau de 15% dans la salle des
bassins de l'institut maurice lamontagne
à mont joli les chercheurs caroline
sonné et denis chabot explore plusieurs
hypothèses pour tenter de comprendre
leur établissement étonnant et
population de sébaste celle qui semble
la plus plausible et qu'elle était bas
font une des robes les pères qui tirent
plutôt bien leur épingle du jeu face au
changement climatique
les chercheurs ont capturé 800 sébaste
dans le saint-laurent pour les exposer
ensuite aux variations de température et
d'acidité qui sont anticipés dans le
golfe d'ici la fin du siècle
le but du projet c'est de pouvoir mieux
prédire à la physiologie les besoins
énergétiques
le taux de croissance le taux de survie
du sébaste aux conditions actuelles et
aux conditions futures
une des victimes du retour en force
sébaste et la crevette nordique
après avoir atteint des niveaux
d'abondance historique sa population a
fortement décliné depuis 2010
pas surprenant puisque le sébaste a fait
de la crevette une de ses principales
proies
une chose est certaine il y aura des
gagnants et des perdants ici comme
ailleurs
et il faudra se montrer recibir car les
changements que nous vivons sont là pour
durer
c'est clair que le golfe du saint
laurent dans 50 ans vont être différent
de celui d'aujourd'hui donc il ya encore
une biodiversité à ce moment alors mais
on europe perdu l'écosystème contrôle
actuellement tout est à mes yeux c'est
une perte pour la planète et pour nous
ce bouleversement mondial des
écosystèmes est un enjeu de taille
l'océan est la plus grande source de
protéines de la planète c'est le garde
manger de plus de 3 milliards d'humains
et ce sont les habitants des pays en
développement qui seront les plus
touchés la raison le réchauffement de
l'eau provoque déjà le déplacement de
nombreuses espèces vers les pôles et va
laisser un vide alimentaire dans les
régions tropicales
mais selon certains scientifiques
les changements climatiques ne sont pas
la seule menace à la survie des stocks
de poissons
la surpêche c'est la raison principale
de lamu déclin de la santé des océans
parce que la surpêche et la pêche en
fait c'est fait pour tuer des poissons
[Musique]
à vancouver au bord du pacifique
daniel pauly dresse un constat accablant
de notre gestion des pêcheries
ce chercheur a consacré sa vie à étudier
l'impact des pêches sur les stocks de
poissons dans la plupart des pays la
surpêche c'est le résultat d'une pêche à
un contrôle et donc là la pêche un
contrôle et ça devient un peu une
surpêche
parmi les espèces qui sont exploités au
maximum de ce qu'elle peuvent endurer on
pense au temps et aux requins la pêche
ne produit rien la pêche ne fait que
ramasser ce que la nature produit des
poissons se palper shirt les produits il
ne fait que les ramasser
selon les chiffres recueillis par l'onu
94 % des stocks de poisson serait à la
limite de leur exploitation ou bien sûr
exploiter mais peut-être est-ce
davantage
le problème c'est que trop souvent on ne
sait pas avec précision ce que les
pêcheurs sortent de l'océan
la méconnaissance des prises réelles des
pêcheries mondiales à cacher une partie
du déclin encore aujourd'hui on a
l'impression que les stocks se maintient
alors qu en fait eu une s'écroule très
saoul
selon lui une des solutions pour en
arriver à mettre en place une pêche
durable serait d'arrêter de maintenir en
vie artificiellement
cette activité économique au détriment
de la ressource tout les chevilles qui a
besoin d'être d'être subventionné a
besoin d'être abandonnés parce qu' elle
ne devrait pas continuer parce que
nature nous dit laissez-moi tranquille
il faut que je me repose il faut que je
me remette
et ce message très clair que la nature
nous donne on n'a pas besoin de
l'écouter quand on est des subventions
donc voilà on continue à pêcher malgré
le fait que les ressources soient
excellent
[Musique]
partout sur la planète les pêcheurs
n'ont pas le choix ils devront continuer
à s'adapter
a pris le bateau comme mon grand père a
fait aussi on va s'habituer avec ce
qu'on arrive ce qui arrive en ce moment
le programme du jour au lendemain il ya
pire son niveau de jeu s'il ya du vent
il serait malheureux at about la planète
complète affecté là dedans a fait 120 go
sport de responsabilité à
mondiale à faire juste pêcheurs c'est
mondial des favoris
[Musique]
après la pause le plastique dans les
océans un fléau aux conséquences
jusqu'ici insoupçonnés
[Musique]
la pollution des océans par le plastique
est une crise d'envergure planétaire est
une chercheuse québécois ans basée en
californie est arrivé à un triste
constat en plus de provoquer la mort de
nombreux animaux marins le plastique en
se dégradant dans les océans
représentent une source de gaz à effet
de serre jusqu'ici méconnue
[Musique]
chaque année on produit plus de 300
millions de tonnes de plastique dans le
monde
[Musique]
selon une étude récente
à peine 9 % de cette matière seraient
recyclés et 12% est sidéré
l'immense majorité des plastiques
79% se retrouvent dans les dépotoirs ou
pire encore dans l'environnement
[Musique]
et quand on parle de rejet dans
l'environnement ce sont des images comme
celles ci qui nous viennent tantale
[Musique]
les scientifiques estiment que chaque
année 8 millions de tonnes de plastique
aboutissent dans les océans
il y en a partout du plastique c'est
ouais c'est sur toutes les plages sa
part le monde
trente secondes de marche depuis j'ai
trouvé cette 8ème de plastique
bouteilles de plastique des emballages
de plastique des complices étaient ses
proches
et un énorme problème
problème incroyable au niveau du
plastique
[Musique]
sarah jane royer est océanographe depuis
quelques années cette scientifique
québécoise alterne ses recherches entre
hawaï et et san diego en californie
sa spécialité les effets de la pollution
des plastiques dans l'océan
aujourd'hui l'homme menace la santé des
océans
mais pour moi un tank océanographes les
audiences et c'est notre réserve en
thermique c'est la vie c'est ce qui nous
permet d'être au monde aujourd'hui est
donc moi je veux protéger les océans
[Musique]
l'impact du plastique sur la santé des
océans elle est immense
chaque minute on environ un camion de
vidange de déchets plastiques y déverser
dans l'océan
[Musique]
le plastique arrive dans l'océan de
partout et sous plusieurs formes
le vent et la pluie transporte vers les
ruisseaux et les rivières des sacs et
bouteilles des pailles et une multitude
d'autres objets pour la plupart à usage
unique qui finissent souvent par aboutir
dans l'océan
s'ajoutent les micro plastiques ces
particules de moins de 5 mm contenues
dans les savons les cosmétiques et les
produits d'entretien qui sont rejetés
dans les égouts et c'est sans compter
toutes les bouées et filets de pêche
fait de matières plastiques qui sont
perdus ou abandonnés en verre
une fois dans l'océan le plastique se
dispersent
ces déchets peuvent parcourir des
milliers de kilomètres
emportés dans le tourbillon des courants
marins l'hégire océanique on en retrouve
cinq sur la planète
sarah jane royer a pu constater leur
impact sur les côtes hawaïennes
on retrouve une quantité phénoménale de
débris marins les plastiques dans l'agir
océanique peuvent résider pendant
plusieurs années puis vont fréquenter
ils vont devenir de plus en plus petit
éventuellement quand il ya une tempête
quand les vents sont plus élevés ces
bouts de plastique vont être rejetés de
la gérer et éventuellement vont se
retrouver sur les plages hawaïennes et
les dommages sont durables on estime que
le plastique peut rester dans
l'environnement durant des centaines
d'années et tenter de finaliser
ce plastique servier de plus en plus un
petit morceau qui est accessible de plus
en plus d'animaux marins puis son petit
donc tous des animaux qui se retrouvent
dans l'océan vont à gérer une plastique
par erreur
les animaux marins du plus petit au plus
grand confondre ces morceaux de
plastique de différentes tailles avec la
nourriture
son la commission océanographique de
l'unesco ces débris cause annuellement
la mort 2 millions d'oiseaux
et c'est sans compter les 100000
mammifères marins qui perdent la vie
empêtré dans des engins de pêche fait de
plastique
mais la pollution par les plastique dans
les océans risquent de causer d'autres
dommages à la planète jusque là
insoupçonnées
parce que le plastique est produit à
partir de combustibles fossiles comme le
pétrole sarah jane royer s'est demandé
si sa dégradation dans l'océan pouvaient
avoir un effet sur la hausse des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre dans
l'atmosphère
pour moi ça ne fait pas une grande
surprise de voir que des gars des
facteurs sont produits par tous du
plastique la surprise était que personne
l'avait étudié sans doute que
l'industrie du pétrole et du plastique
est au courant mais il fallait qu'un
scientifique à un moment donné faire
face seules découvertes et puis la
publicité anti ficm ans afin que ce soit
connue
elle et son équipe ont fait des tests
sur le polyéthylène la sorte de
plastique qu'on retrouve le plus dans
l'océan ils ont démontré que plus un
objet sera ghm en plus il offre une
grande surface aux rayons du soleil
ainsi il émet davantage de gaz et
deviennent encore plus nocifs pour
l'environnement
commencée que le temps de vie de
plastique est énorme des centaines
d'années bas ce plastique va va
continuer à produire ces gaz à effet de
serre sur une échelle de temps
incroyable
je crois que l'industrie du plastique ne
pas tellement aimé la publication
d'essayer de travailler la dc du
plastique lors de mes recherches j'ai
demandé de l'aide j'ai essayé d'ouvrir
des portes discuter avec l'industrie du
plastique puis à chaque fois ils y ont
fermé les ports paiement dit qu'ils
pouvaient pas avant de communication
avec moi
l'industrie n'a pas de quoi s'inquiéter
depuis le début de la pandémie de kovy
19 la consommation de plastique à usage
unique aurait augmenté de 250 à 300 %
aux états-unis seulement
à l'échelle de la planète des chercheurs
ont calculé que la production de
plastique va doubler d'ici 15 ans et
quadruples et d'ici 2050
plusieurs pensent qu'il est désormais
urgent de revoir notre mode de vie
on est complètement des maisons une
autre conservation plastique
si vous voulez consommer consommer avec
un esprit vers aussi de réfléchir à
votre un pack à votre fauteuil qu'est ce
que vous laissez derrière vous pour vous
consommez un produit
pour protéger notre sang nous amène le
but
vous amène une partie de notre
nourriture
on doit faire attention à ce qu'on fait
ensemble pour s'assurer que la planète
ait enfanté
[Musique]
après la pause comment envisager
l'avenir des océans
[Musique]
est il trop tard pour sauver les océans
un peu partout à travers le monde des
scientifiques et des citoyens s'unissent
pour trouver des solutions mais cela
prendra des efforts considérables
notamment pour se défaire de notre
dépendance aux plastiques il faudra
aussi une volonté ferme des dirigeants
de la planète pour éviter le pire
les océans n'ont jamais été aussi
malmené et les conséquences pour
l'avenir de l'humanité se font déjà
sentir
c'est pourquoi les nations unies ont
proclamé que cette décennie sera celle
des sciences océaniques au service du
développement durable
devant l'urgence les scientifiques du
monde entier seront mis à contribution
pour tenter d'inverser le déclin des
océans avant qu'il ne soit trop tard
ce sentiment d'urgence a trouvé écho à
columbus en ohio c'est là qu'habite
cathy sur le veut
l'astronaute et océanographes nous a
donné rendez vous aux cossaye le centre
de sciences qu'elle a dirigé et où ses
prouesses sont immortalisés mais comparé
dans la navette ont pris ce faute aussi
c'est lors de ce vol à bord de la
navette challenger en 1984 que cathy
sans heaven inscrit son nom dans le
grand livre de la vente sur aérospatiale
des états unis celle face qu un des qg
la première femme maire de kani à
marcher dans l'espace
[Musique]
ce n'est qu'un début
cathy sort leeuwen va ensuite réalisé
deux autres missions spatiales avant
d'être nommé scientifique en chef de
l'anneau à la prestigieuse agence
américaine responsable de l'étude de
l'océan et de l'atmosphère
à ce moment là scientifique comprend
qu'elle peut faire une réelle différence
âgées sentais vraiment que seulement de
voir cette opportunité fantastique de
voir notre propre planète ce point de
vue il faut que je retourne sur terre et
trouver les moyens d'un protêt cette
perspective a les jambes je dis en
anglais
mais quand même
mais le goût de l'aventuré n'est jamais
bien loin en 2020 cathy son neveu est
invité à plonger à bord deux
submersibles dans la fosse des mariannes
l'objectif descendre jusqu'au point
nommé charline jeudi l'endroit le plus
profond jamais mesuré dans les océans à
plus de dix mille neuf cent mètres sous
le niveau de la mer
j'ai lu beaucoup de papier des livres au
sujet de tchaoudjo libre même d'être là
de le voir moi-même mes yeux
c'est qu'ils ont peut pas résister je ne
peux pas résister bien sûr j'y vais
elle devient alors le premier être
humain à avoir marché dans l'espace et à
s'être aussi rendu au point le plus
profond des océans
une expédition hors du commun
et c'est comme un ascenseur quatre
ascenseurs serine cole
général
les rares humains qui s'aventurent à ces
profondeurs ont droit à tout un
spectacle
c'est ça qu'il est pour moi la magie
klaus y en partout dans notion on trouve
la vie
tous les espaces tout l'équipe tous les
formes que les adaptations de la vie
partout dans l'option c'est un miracle
si merveilleuse
et puis on est arrivé sur le fond
c'était comme la paysage de la lune
mais les fosses abyssales réserve aussi
de triste surprise
on a trouvé le plastique au plus profond
région de lotion
on est en profondeur de 11 mm e au
centre de plus de noël et quand même les
déchets humaines sont des auteurs d'un
but partout
nous les hommes nous sont partout sur
terre nous sommes partout
tant motion
les humains sont ils allés trop loin
dans son rapport sur l'océan le groupe
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat le giec crois
qu'il est encore possible de sauver la
mise
plus nous agirons rapidement et de
manière décisive plus nous serons en
mesure de faire face aux changements
inévitables et d'assurer la durabilité
des écosystèmes et des populations du
monde entier
l'appel a été entendu
en gaspésie les pêcheurs sont conscients
de l'ampleur de la tâche mais il croit
qu'il est toujours possible de changer
la donne un examen c'est ce que beaucoup
changé nos habitudes de vie pas mal tout
le monde qui a changé sont à base de
données est plus je te dise pockets et
savoir durer encore un million d'années
mais au moins pour le tac ça va durer au
mont royal pour faire des efforts pied
assez de préserver la continuté
partout sur la planète des initiatives
voient le jour pour tenter d'enrayer le
déclin des océans
en floride par exemple des scientifiques
ont réussi à reproduire une espèce de
corail en laboratoire il pense être en
mesure de restaurer les récifs de coraux
nécessaires à la vie marine et qui sont
menacées de disparition
des programmes de certifications ont été
créés ici et ailleurs pour aider les
consommateurs à choisir des poissons et
des fruits de mer pêchés ou produits de
façon durable
de nouvelles technologies sont aussi
développées pour débarrasser les océans
du plastique
et partout des corps vie sont organisés
pour nettoyer les plages et les fonds
marins
à san diego en californie
l'océanographe sarah-jane royer a
justement décidé de passer à l'action
pour contrer cette pollution causée par
les déchets plastiques
donc ici on va sélectionner les petits
bouts microplastiques elle et son
conjoint élabore une application pour
téléphone mobile qui mise sur la
participation citoyenne et
l'intelligence artificielle les citoyens
vont prendre des photos de bouts de
plastique sur des plages sont des roches
sur les zones côtières en général ces
photos vont être partagé avec nous puis
à l'aide de l'algorithme on va calculer
les concentrations de plastique à
travers le monde
mais tous ces efforts citoyens ne seront
pas suffisants il faut que les pays
travaillent ensemble sur un but commun
parce que tous ces problèmes ils sont
plus grands que chaque et ils sont plus
grands que le plus grand pays il s'agit
tout leurs pneus prêtes il faudra
l'action commun de toute l'humanité
[Musique]
un exemple de ce que peuvent faire les
nations c'est la création d'aires
marines protégées
des zones où les activités humaines sont
strictement encadrées et où la pêche est
souvent interdite les aires marines
protégées une fois qu'elles sont créées
elles produisent plus de poissons pour
les pêcheurs qui travaillent dans les
dents les angles non protégés et ça
c'est quelque chose qu'on qui est bien
établie par tous
il y a encore du travail à faire au
canada et pour l'ensemble de la planète
moins de 10% des zones côtières et
océaniques bénéficie du stade sud aires
marines protégées
malgré ces aires protégées
la pression demeure forte sur le milieu
marin
à preuve ottawa vient d'autoriser
l'industrie pétrolière a effectué 40
forage exploratoire en mer au large de
terre-neuve une région pourtant reconnue
par l'onu pour son importance écologique
et biologique
le gouvernement
doit se baser sur la science si un
gouvernement ne se base pas sur la
science c'est le chaos aérien de marche
et c'est pour ça que les ressources se
casse la figure partout
le chaos peut être éviter
des étoiles aux fosses abyssales
le parcours de 400 leuven lui permet de
croire en un avenir meilleur et ce sont
les nouvelles générations qui devront
montrer la route
je dirais aux jeunes que votre couette
créativité votre intelligence votre
passion on en a besoin le point d'être
en a besoin elle le dira que toi tu as
l'occasion c'est ici que je vis tout est
unifiée avec tout cela alors tu peux
faire une différence il faut vraiment
que de façon différente ont leur revers
et travailler fort
et vas-y
[Musique]
qui se lancent aujourd'hui en
agriculture un aperçu
[Musique]
la semaine prochaine à l'émission se
lancer en agriculture
c'est un peu comme faire un saut dans le
vide il faut beaucoup d'audace de la
volonté une grande passion pour le
métier portraits de jeunes inspirant qui
ont fait le choix de vivre de la terre
j'ai fini second âge reste beaucoup de
questions let's go en serval t à 5,5
celui/celle appelés à renouveler les
générations en agriculture
arrive un peu bousculée
par les attentes des consommateurs les
grands accords commerciaux les normes
sanitaires ou la protection de
l'environnement ils joignent les rangs
d'un groupe qui fait face à d'énormes
défis on a confié la production
d'aliments à moins d'un pour cent de la
population
voilà c'est ainsi que prend pas notre
émission merci d'être fidèle au rendez
vous et bonne semaine verte
[Musique]